Speaker 1: Some interesting legal news that I
want to go over relating to the ongoing legal
troubles of the failed former president
and his associates. First and foremost,
very interesting report from Bloomberg.
Prosecutors believe that they have the
evidence to charge Donald Trump on the basis
of the investigation connected to the search
warrant served at Mar a Lago. The let's take a
look at this Bloomberg report. Trump Prosecutors
see evidence for obstruction charges. No decision
on charges has been made by DOJ in records probe.
That's an important detail. A bunch of tweets were
floating around yesterday. Sometimes I wonder,
can people actually read news articles?
As soon as this was published yesterday,
all sorts of tweets started floating around. A
decision has been made. Trump is getting charged.
The the subheadline is no decision on charges
has been made in that records probe. Timing
politics and debate over charges are among the
considerations. And that's an area of significant
concern that we should all be worried about and we
will get to it in a moment. Here is what Bloomberg
writes. A group of Justice Department prosecutors
believe there is enough evidence to charge Trump
with obstruction of justice. But the path
to an actual indictment is far from clear.
The team that's part of the classified records
probe has not yet made a formal recommendation to
Merrick Garland, who would ultimately approve or
reject such a move, according to people familiar
with the matter. It's also unlikely officials
would bring only obstruction charges amid
several other Trump investigations into potential
crimes. Now, this is the part that I don't love.
In addition, while some FBI agents oppose bringing
such a politically charged case as Trump considers
a 2024 presidential bid, others support action,
said the people who asked for anonymity because
this is not yet public. Agents, however, don't
make final decisions. The Justice Department
has publicly indicated obstruction is part of its
probe into the mishandling of classified records,
noting there was probable cause for the charge
in the August five FBI search warrant application
for Trump's Mar a Lago estate. No charges are
likely to be filed or publicly revealed before
the November eight elections and perhaps only
after the Christmas holiday. The people said.
One other note here, Frank Fig Lucey, former
FBI assistant director for counterintelligence,
said, quote, Of all the things Trump is
being investigated for around the country,
obstruction of justice is a slam dunk. And I
think he's going to be indicted. I don't see
why a charge of obstruction of justice couldn't
be filed by the end of the year. So listen. Charge
him. It's time. Okay. We've had enough of
this. It's really simple. Consider. I mean,
forget about Georgia, forget about the NY. But
just focusing on this case investigation alone.
Did the did authorities know that Trump had
these files? And then they went to him and said,
you've got to return these files. Yes. We they
knew he had them and they asked for those files
to be returned. Did Donald Trump return them?
The answer is no. We know that because they
found files when they executed a search warrant
at Trump's Mar a Lago. Do we now know that Donald
Trump was aware that they had files, directed
staff to move them, directed a lawyer to lie,
and claimed that they had been given back? I
mean, all of these obstructive acts. Yes, yes,
yes, yes, yes. So is it time for an indictment?
Of course it is. Of course. Of course it is. Now,
what I'm not thrilled about is this discussion
about FBI agents do or don't want the charges
levied because it could impact the midterms. So
they're going to wait until later. But then it
could impact Trump if he decides to run in 2024
or whatever. Listen. If there are charges that
follow logically from the evidence, not charging
Trump because it might have a political impact is
just a political a decision as saying let's charge
him in order to make it have a political impact.
The apolitical thing to do here is that those
in law enforcement look at the evidence. They
compare the evidence to the law, and they decide,
is there sufficient evidence that a law was broken
such that we are going to levy charges? You don't
calculate the timing based on political effect or
whatever else. Think back to the 2016 election,
by the way, where then FBI Director James Comey
did one press conference about Hillary Clinton's
emails. And then as far as we knew, that was it.
There weren't going to be charges coming, etc.,
etc.. And then right before the 2016 election, for
some reason that we still don't really understand.
James Comey does another press conference about
Hillary's emails and we now believe we can't say
any one thing led to Trump winning and Hillary
losing. But it was certainly another little
factor that served as a reminder of, oh yeah,
that thing, even though obviously no charges
are coming. That may have pushed some people
away from Hillary Clinton and to Donald Trump. If
there was any politically oriented, politically
motivated timing for the FBI doing something. It
would be that here we have enough probable cause
for the search warrant to be executed. We now
have colloquially speaking, as laypeople. All
of the elements that make up obstruction by
Donald Trump, knowingly directing people to lie
and hide documents, all these different things.
And at this point, this idea of, well, we don't
we don't necessarily want to charge him because it
might affect a future run for president. He hasn't
even announced. Well, opting not to charge
for that very reason is also a politically
motivated decision. And it's absolutely pathetic.
It is just as politically charged not to charge
someone because it might hurt their chances at
winning an elected office, as it is to say, well,
let's deliberately charge him now if the evidence
is there and the investigation has been completed
and it points to this person likely committed
this crime, then you just have to levy charges.
In that said, we will see if it happens. It's
not going to happen before the November election.
It's abundantly clear at this point in time.
But if and when it happens, when will it be